picture the last game you attend the
seats filled fans cheering concessions
buzzing and the lines well those are
always two long stadiums and arenas now
sit empty as leagues postponed or
canceled games because of the corona
virus pandemic the natural question is
when will sporting events come back but
to understand when it's important to
remember why fans aren't filling the
stadiums now one of the things that we
learned from watching dr. pouchy is the
statement you know we don't control the
timeline you know the virus does if that
means not having any people in the
audience when the NBA plays so be it
sitting shoulder-to-shoulder with other
fans reaching for a high-five after a
big play and grabbing food from
concessions all make the game more fun
and potentially more dangerous I think
about the stadium the same way as I
think about nursing homes cruise ships
jails and prisons it's among the highest
risk areas so let's take a look at the
risks proximity contact and the shared
environment to see why the stadium is
primed for the spread of the corona
virus first proximity when the virus is
trying to do is transfer itself from
somebody's nose or mouth to somebody
else's nose the mouth I'm the easiest
way for that virus to do so it's just
going there directly this typically
happens through droplets when we talk
respiratory droplets can jump from you
to another person but only if you're
close but fluid droplet is a little bit
heavy and it's gonna fall within 3 feet
if somebody isn't there to catch it on
the Sun only 3 feet next to you is 3
feet before and behind you as well
that's why the CDC recommends people
keep a distance of at least 6 feet from
each other 3 feet plus a buffer
according to doctors now let's bring the
game into it
that cheering or yelling in propel
infectious eating droplets beyond three
feet like a sneeze the force of a screen
can also create much smaller particles
called aerosols these are lighter so
they can linger in the air for more time
and travel further the stadium setting
is really conducive for that because
it's not only about the one-time
immediate risk it's the amount of hours
of contacts so even though the one time
aerosol is not gonna do much in the real
world you have like constantly people
shouting over many hours at some point
the cumulative risk is going to be
greater than the actual individual risk
of the act itself in other words the
more exposure the higher the chance
you'll be infected that brings us to the
next important risk factor prolonged
contact not every interaction results in
getting an infection it's very unlikely
for three people sitting next to each
other closely in the stadium to give it
to each other in a domino effect because
the virus has to incubate in the second
person first before that second person
can then transmit it to the third person
an incubation usually occurs within
seven days but games last for hours and
that gives the virus plenty of
opportunities to succeed in spreading
from one infected person to several
healthy people in their vicinity in the
stadium one of the issues that makes it
very challenging to protect spectators
from kubja 19 is social contact from my
experience social contact is one of the
joys of even going to the steam in the
first place on February 19th
before the corona virus had really taken
hold in Italy a soccer match filled the
stadium in San Siro while it's very
difficult to pinpoint the game as the
key moment of transmission two weeks
later coronavirus cases in the Lombardy
region shot up experts have pointed to
matches like that as potential super
spreader events fans want to hug fist
and chest bump and revel in the emotion
of the game over and over again I think
of the stadium as an adult's preschool
there's a lot of slobbering there's a
lot of secretions
the virus fails to directly land on a
person's face and infect them that way
it has other means let's take the
celebratory high-five
so you are touching somebody's hand with
the high-five and even if you're able to
steal we drink that high-five you're
gonna be potentially contaminated in
your hands and then when you touch your
face you're wiping that sweat away
you're going to be introducing potential
virus into your nauseum of contaminated
surfaces are another key risk factor and
it's not just body parts think bathrooms
concession stands liters hand railings
shared food and beverages and the
containers they come in tens of
thousands of people can touch some of
these objects and smear them with virus
that can end up on someone's hands and
then face this indirect mode of
infection is known as faux mite
transmission while scientists think it's
less efficient than direct transmission
through droplets contaminated surfaces
abound in stadiums to prevent filmic
transmission good personal hygiene is
critical that means constant hand
washing or hand sanitizing perhaps them
the most important challenge in the
stadium is human you might be able to
control your own hygiene and wear your
own masks but what about the thousands
of fans and seats around you to get
through this you can require a great
deal of social trust washing your hands
of social trust cover your cough is
social trust wearing a mask serves as a
barrier limiting how far you're
potentially virus Laden droplets can fly
and the number of surfaces they can
contaminate with Kovach 19 there's a
fair amount of asymptomatic transmission
so people who don't feel sick are more
likely to show up to games and then
spread the virus without widespread
testing it's harder to identify mild
cases and isolate them
[Music]
we're trying to map out you know we sell
about eighty-five thousand season
tickets including students so if you
have a hundred and three thousand seats
you know that gives you you know
eighteen thousand empty seats you know
after your season ticket base and so
physically you know all eighty-five
thousand people would not fit if we have
to socially distance Texas A&M athletic
director Ross Bjork says it's too early
to say what if anything will change
before the fall football season games
for now is still on things were canceled
pretty much in a uniform you know basis
and a lot of coordination but it's
things start to go the other way and
open up there's not a clear indication
of okay this governing body can make
this decision for all of college sports
that question is playing out across
America as economies start to open up
again Texas was among the first states
to reboot certain industries while
trying to balance medical and economic
risks don hasn't included sports yet but
as we look at procedures around you know
best practices for restaurants they're
looking at all those things so I think
we can in a lot of ways model you know
what the restaurant industry is doing
restaurants have limited the number of
customers that can come in for fans a
big part of the transition back to the
stadium will be adjusting to a new
normal I think an important corollary I
think about a lot is before and after
9/11 so before 9/11 you go to a stadium
you know you wouldn't expect it a metal
detector you wouldn't expect a pat-down
and now that's we're waiting lions and
queues for that right that's expected
for stadiums
it could mean playing the game with
fewer fans or none at all limiting
concessions opting for mobile payments
and even giving spectators entrance and
exit times that past visual what the
game was like is going to be very
different in the near future and I think
that's okay in fact I think people will
expect that in order to feel comfortable
you
[Music]